herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich sitze hier zusammen mit
dem lukas meili leute ich sitz hier
zusammen mit luca und wir spielen heute
noch mal ein game aus dem google places
aber wir spielen nicht einfach nur das
game wir spielen das game machen das
game quasi noch mal in realität na also
eine doppelte challenge wichtige fragen
die leute kommen her sagen ja komm ich
schaue mir ja das ist zwar in einem
video würde sagen wir beginnt ja das war
die mobile gaming teil und dafür habe
ich mir diese app heruntergeladen ihr
seht ihr jetzt eingeblendet flick schon
zwei heißt das ganze vor sondern machen
ja man schießt freistöße und es gibt
unterschiedliche spielmodi wir werden
uns heute ein aus erstmal prinzipiell
die google playboy wir zocken einfach
nur mobile games haben keine krassen
vorgaben voll entspannt für uns ich
hoffe auch für euch der spielmodus team
wie heute spielen heißt du musst treffen
denn wir machen das gleiche ganz hier
erstmals um dein name weckt fischen
wollen die fort das ist dein erstes mal
dort dann wissen mit deinem handy
aufnehmen das ist mein name freunde oder
ja ich spiele jetzt du musst treffen ich
klicke einfach mal drauf da siehst du
mich das bin ich also das weißt du auch
hier sieht auch schon aus wie luca und
wir klicken jetzt einfach mal aufspielen
dann kommt ein countdown ich klar ich
mache mich schon mal ein bisschen heiß
und dann beginne ich mit den freistößen
ich muss jeden treffen ein einziges mal
da ich verschießen alter habe ich gerade
in der luft noch das kann man machen du
kannst am anfang so ein bisschen drill
geben und in der luft noch ja denen
jemand nicht easy ist auch kein mal
gespielt ja ich will jetzt zum zweiten
mal aber das ist ja das ja die challenge
para siehst du das ist einfach so ein
kleines game was man so zum 2 vertrag
spielen kann und so wir gucken einfach
wer hier mehr punkte hatten dem anderen
spieler punkte arthur 210 habe ich jetzt
geht's auch drinnen weiß ich mache das
hier ist alles drin
der alte dessauer jetzt richtig
auslassen will ich treffe mein gott
braucht oder jetzt jetzt langweilt war
in residence krass weit weg ich musste
schon gut schießen verdammt dass das war
schon verloren marie tore habe ich
geschossen acht tore
das ist viel ich dachte die ganze zeit
wäre so mega einfach aber der letzte war
echt schwer
luca würde sagen dass mein erstes mal
gerade
erstes mal dass du spielst ich bin recht
nervös gerade ich weiß ja direkt unter
die latte gemeißelt wenn man jetzt habe
ich dann ein bisschen nach recht aber
dann sollte nach regens aber beim junge
war so ich habe sagen da ist er wieder
drin 50 punkt dort waren nur 30 uhr auf
der seite und waren 109 200 was man da
noch mal zehn und jetzt hier und bahn ab
zur seite noch mal ziehen und hier und
noch mal und wunder 320 punkte schon
leute was ist los ich bin sogar arme ich
hab mir abwehrspieler schon bei mir
schon eine mauer die kraft ich schieße
dir neben der war und die tour sehen
verdammt ja das ging jetzt echt schnell
alter wir spieler aber nochmals
verstärken wir sind jetzt eingespielt
wollte eigentlich nur einmal machen aber
jetzt machen wir insgesamt drei runden
wer insgesamt von drei runden die
meisten tore hat über 10 ist der
aktuelle rekord von luca sehen ja das
ganze ja ja ich dachte wenn ich hatte
ihnen die 320 punkte oder so aber max
ist ja auch schon gut mit dabei ja das
war ich glaube es aber wirklich so wenig
ecken schießt nicht mal mehr punkte oder
oder unter die lage irgendwie so in die
ecke unter die latte winkel kreuz gibt
wahrscheinlich am allermeisten punkte
aber winkel kreuz das sagen halt nur
nicht das niveau gehalten dittmann ist
wie viele tore waren das 77 noch weniger
glück und schloss sich verschlechtert
noch weniger als gerade locker er sagte
er hat es nie gespielt punkt war wieder
so viel gespielt junges zehn punkte noch
mal und noch mal 30 punkte und ich gönne
mir und punkte sind ja egal was kommt
auf die tore an
ehrlich wir nicht punkten nur auf die
tore nicht schießt ideen immer sind die
ecken und weil du einfach krass bist ja
also irgendwie besser als anfangs
wartete warst du lachst so aber sind
neun tore okay du hast aber gerade schon
zehn ja also ich habe gewonnen ich weiß
es kommt näher
wer in sand am main bei einem versuch
leute wenn ihr mehr mobile gaming sehen
wollt einfach mal hier oben in der ecke
ab stimmig blender selbst eine
abstimmung ein und wenn ihr lust auf
mehr hat dann sagen wir bescheid das
können ja auch so changes wert sein
erster schuss sie mal in der fast gehabt
das kitz weiter ich muss jetzt erstmal
safe machen
alter schwede der gesehen der war nicht
geil war direkt neben den torwart aber
der zum glück versagt der staat ist auch
ein bisschen einmal machen ok meisters
drin
ich spiele donald trump gerade und ich
bin schon wieder verändert hat sieht es
echt gemerkt wer das handy hat okay das
könnte jetzt etwas werben vielleicht
schaffe ich jetzt über zehn das war
natürlich bitter wenn du bescheuert mich
heute aufgerüstet steht da gerade fakt
ist besser geworden
okay das alter ein 30 meter wieder alter
weißenfeldt wir sind links um wir sind
mädchen blau und das recht ist der
torwart
ich will jetzt nicht sagen aber es läuft
gerade vor ein bisschen bei mir halt ja
und in dem moment einfach nicht auf der
linie und das waren wie viele tore 14
okay das kratzt das versuche ich jetzt
zu toppen alter der flug richtig
spannend für glück habe ich noch ein
bisschen länger gefragt was ist drin und
gar kein problem der auch unten in die
ecke direkt die 30 punkte mir gegönnt
davor eine junge kriegt er auch nicht in
das problem die besucher wieder haut wie
die er macht ihr lokal nur über den
pfosten nein das hat er gehalten
ich weiß ich bin ich mache das immer zu
schnell ohne spaß waren noch fünf tore
der wert jetzt damit gewonnen ich nenne
ich habe zweimal dreimal ja ja gesagt
wir am meisten ins gesagt leute ja mit
habe ich den ersten teil der fans
geworden und jetzt gehen wir in sri
lanka das hier ist unser tor
das hat mich geholt ja man hat es ja
ganz alleine geholt habe es jetzt
aufgebaut du bist jetzt der torhüter ok
so bleibt sitzen
wir nehmen jetzt die kamera ab und mache
jetzt eine fussball challenge hier drin
leute wie sie jetzt angekommen im
mühlacker challenge die allererste
freischuss aufgabe ist aufgebaut hier
ist der ball wieder stärker und da ist
das tor es ist quasi
und machbar also geschafft das macht
weiter tate ist jetzt nicht mehr so
leicht denn von der seite wir steigern
uns dann langsam macht zwei tore hast du
ja wie denkst jetzt das ist schon
geschafft und du bist grafik so eine
seite des guten ist der torwart kommt
das wird schon deutlich anspruchsvoller
dich bewegst alter und guter torwart
grafite legt erneut probieren wir sind
jetzt wieder fit rentiert abschuss luca
ja du musst den toyota zieren den
kasseninhalt jetzt wird es richtig
schwierig der ball liegt hier was diese
seite er das tor kommt so hin verstehen
die leute halten kannst du überlegen ob
du den wind gibt dort wurde waren spiels
bin dass ich beides geben zitiert muss
überlegen also wenn der ball da und die
schieße den dagegen vor mallorca
verbracht einfach reingehen und topia
und ja leute hier sind dabei hier ist
der torwart
hier ist es tot ich würde ihn halten
aber ich weiß dass mit diesem ball hart
schwierig ist den zu lupfen weil er
einfach zu leicht ist aber ich werde die
luft und zwar so weit will bald wieder
rausgekommen takt für takt eine schule
so leute nächste aufgabe der ball nimmt
hier zusammen mit blut und wir machen
jetzt ein distanzschuss das tor ist ganz
dahinten wünsche viel erfolg sehr 7
läuft an und da war das ding aber ich
muss sagen nicht schlecht als er dabei
liegt an meiner motivation was später
für immer unkenntlich grenzenlos
okay ich bin den ball lege ich einfach
mal die vorne hin und sie müssten direkt
von hier vorne dann das tor steht zudem
noch der bayerischen weg weil wir das so
oft ja dazu sage ich doch nur paul das
tor würde ich sagen was immer wir stehen
allerdings wir wären jetzt auch für dich
eine etwas andere position und zwar sage
ich mal direkt du musst im sitzen den
ball reinmachen creme maximus sitzen und
du musstest dort treffen nicht daneben
schießen
du darfst du willst du musst nur sitzen
bleiben also mal schauen ob er das tor
treffen wird der schwerpunkt diesmal auf
jeder wird nicht einfach super schlecht
also ich bin nicht gut im fußball das
weiß nicht aber irgendwie es im sitzen
echt schwer alles klar leute da habe ich
jetzt sagen wir haben sind sieger der
zweiten challenge und klären wer der
gesamtsieger ist wie echte männer
wir machen eine hochhalten wettet okay
wir klären das mit dem hoch halten wäre
das der hochhalten kann aber direkt an
aller erster versuch geht's los
los gehts es laut mit 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
als sind jetzt seit 1916
17 18 ein recht viele geräte klein ich
habe schon verloren
18 hatte ich ja noch mal wäre das
gedacht waren fußball change spiele ich
ja ich bin einfach nicht gut im fußball
aber dafür habe ich beim mobile gaming
gewann ja das stimmt wenn ihr mehr
mobile gaming sehen wollt freundin
findet ihr immer noch oben die
abstimmung eingeblendet so leute das
war's von uns dreien hier misst
agrarminister kornmesser tel
dass dabei ist tut mir leid habe ich
vergessen dass hier noch ein weiteres
mobile gaming video sehen wollt verlege
ich euch das unten in der beschreibung
und dadurch sagen sie mir das beim
nächsten mal bis dahin und